yesterday during a conference in
Washington Democratic senator mazie
Hirono explaining why Democrats have a
hard time connecting with voters that
just too smart we'll get to that in a
minute but first joining us is former
Speaker of the House author of the
bestseller Trump's America the truth
about our nation's great comeback Newt
Gingrich all right when you read this
thing on general Flynn we find out okay
that there are only two known instances
in which individuals have been indicted
for violating the Logan Act the last of
which came at 1853 and neither
indictment resulted in conviction and
the other one that's mentioned is the
the federal law and we know that the DOJ
issued a report that tallied all the
prosecutions onto fara since 1966 that
would be seven cases with one conviction
is this how deep we go to get a guy that
served 33 years in the military that the
FBI didn't believe was lying sure you
have to understand Muller is not
involved in a investigation Miller has a
trump destruction project he brought on
a team all of them dedicated to
destroying Trump they've done everything
they could to destroy Trump and part of
that technique would which frankly
Sidney Powell described brilliantly in
her book license to lie about the
Justice Department part of that
technique is you throw the kitchen sink
you basically threaten somebody and say
I'm going to bankrupt you I'm going to
put your son in jail I want to charge
you with so many different crimes you'll
never get out from under it now would
you like to talk and when you have the
full power of the federal government
against you it's pretty tough not to try
to find a way to get them off your back
but it has nothing to do with the truth
there's nothing to do with justice and
in Mueller I think it'll really sad
historians someday will comment that
this was one of the most extraordinary
efforts to undo the will of the American
people by and established bureaucracy
and its establishment friends that we've
seen in all of American history and then
I want to make one quick point just to
put this in context Donald Trump after
92% negative coverage for two years
92% negative coverage for two years it's
somewhere between 44 and 48 percent
approval depending on the poll Ronald
Reagan about this point in nineteen two
thousand nineteen eighty-three was at
thirty five percent the fact is that
McCrone the wonderboy of France is now
down at twenty-five or twenty-six
percent and just had the worst riots in
Paris in fifty years so the whole notion
that Muller is now the person who's
going to go out and save America by
destroying the president I think is an
aunt like the institutional effort by
the organized left so John Solomon just
breaks this story now we knew that they
didn't verify the dossier and it was not
corroborated which is part of their
protocol and also part of the law but
now we see an email chain where they
knew it had massive credibility problems
this is what he discovered an email
chain with all of these people's names
in it that shows they knew that there
were credibility problems to the very
evidence that the the bulk of evidence
that was used to obtain the FISA
warrants the in the FISA applications
and they withheld all of that
exculpatory information from the judges
as well as who paid for it which was
Hillary and how it was a political
document how can they get away with that
abuse of power well because they're the
establishment they're the fix they're
the insiders they're the guys at the New
York Times The Washington Post and all
the networks except for Fox all surround
and protect them now they operated on a
premise and of course they all thought
Hillary is going to win so they never
thought this would come to light they
thought they were helping the winner and
I think it was an enormous shock
election night to suddenly start for
Comey in particular to suddenly start
realizing that his neck was on the line
he'd been breaking the law but he always
thought he'd be protected everybody near
the Clintons have been protected as you
point away call me his name is
email change is on the email chain he
signed off on that of course you had you
had the director of the Federal Bureau
of Investigation actively trying to
destroy a presidential candidate
you have the former head of the FBI Bob
Muller actively trying to destroy the
president nine states I mean there's a
pointer and I know it's frustrating but
the fact is this is a clear-cut drama
they hate him they want to destroy him
has nothing to do with the truth and
nothing to do with the law there's no if
we don't get everyone else that lied
that we know lied under oath if
Hillary's never held accountable you
could say we have no equal justice or
application or laws that's the scary
part of every American mr. speaker thank
you